My God !! You did not say that to Miss, so to Miss My Lady!
- So what ?
- There are those who like to tell him that you look like a jerk in a circus!
Oh Lord!
- You are naughty!
"No, but you are the villain."
- You, Sabaya .. Bad news bulletin!
- So, Sabaya!
- Do you want to watch some videos on the net .. or not?
- Play some anti-bored games!
Do you know what we have not done for a while?
- The Challenge of Truth or Dread
-How .. to do!
- If oh sweet!
Start first!
Truth or courage?
- Ummmam. Truth!
- ..
Who is the man of your dreams of celebrity?
-Laaa .. Let's ask this question!
- It looks like it 's traditionally ... but
I seem to have some admiration for Liam Hemswoth!
- Naughty!
- How stupid you are!
- Well, your turn, Amanda!
Truth or courage?
-Ah
- How difficult this is!
-M
Courage!
- Okay
- I found the idea!
-Amanda
- I test your courage with a challenge ...
Ryan accused of assault!
- Uh !
- This is madness!
Exactly!
The chance to put him in jail is impossible!
- It's a white man!
- This is not the focus of the topic!
- Case we are bored!
And we need something exciting to do!
I think you're right!
Give me your phone!
I'll call the police right now.
Hi!
- It does not seem complete!
- What were you wearing that night?
- I do not know what is related to the case?
But I was dressed in Manama.
- Oh!
I knew it!
- As you see, my dear. Manama Homecoming Sleepwear!
When I got intimacy !!
- I am the focus of attention here, do you feel jealous?
Can you describe what happened that night?
- Oh Imm I have been mentioned without my permission.
-After two weeks-
What a disaster!
Compel you to change your home and town!
- Honestly
All these threats I will receive at school
I became worried about my father!
- I also can not identify new friends.
- Of course it has become an old coin!
Focus on 'brutality'!
I have read the police report about your madness.
- My father read the report ..
They looked at me differently
So that my father did not look at me directly a week ago!
Parents never understand!
very!
after a year !
Amanda, welcome!
Here is Candy and Gabriel!
- it has been a long time !
Want to know your latest news?
Aah .. You know! I'm still in court !! It is likely to start after a few months
Maybe I still need some time ..
- I have not registered in the university yet ..
It has consumed my time!
- But it's worth it in the end.
- with people's sympathy in the means of social communication!
- I'm in a fun mood all the time ..
- is not it?
- It is funny and honest
- Well, because I gave it my best.
And now your role, Gabrielle in the game ..
Truth or courage?
- End-